due to the pandemic and safety concerns
this year's ceremony was dramatically
scaled back from 2009
when e.t first saw then vice president
biden and president obama sworn in
what an historic day this is security
was very tight there were long waits it
took us about three hours to get
actually inside the perimeter to the
spot we're in right now
the scene surrounding the capitol was
nothing short of breathtaking 1.8
million people lining the national mall
in frigid 28 degree weather
to witness history i said to michelle a
little nervous
she said don't screw it up
it's everything it's electric it just
brings absolute joy to my soul
and the feelings kept flowing through
the night when the president and first
lady took their first dance with the
help of beyonce
[Music]
i thought that was a beautiful moment
though it was beautiful what you thought
i thought
that's the trick e.t has witnessed so
many inaugurations over the years
in 2001 ricky martin and jessica simpson
welcomed the newly sworn in president
george w bush
[Music]
i sang for clinton and i'm singing for
bush and i'm just here
to support and back in 1993
singing legend dion warwick was our et
correspondent in washington for
president clinton's star-studded first
inauguration
yeah we're kind of young but that's so
big though
we're standing with the fresh friends
this is the first time in my life that
i've
really been politically active i'm 24
years old